hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen adventure web
und zwar epic skype zusammen mit gome hd
parallel leute so und wir haben uns
gedacht ist wird diese map
zusammenspielen es ist glaube ich die
weiß nicht wievielten edition von diesem
epic du meintest der dritte wer die
dritte oder die politischen starter
edition und welcome to the peak jump ich
würde vorschlagen wir gucken uns hier
erst mal um oder genauer texture pack
dafür drin
das wäre zum beispiel das inventar hier
unten so ein bisschen komisch an ja habe
ich so komische goldnuggets drauf ja
natürlich alles super eingestellt mit
comment blogs und normal difficult tut
alles was ist das hier holte liverpool
fitter sind work pixelgenaue spiel mal
eine runde gott hier in minecraft
ich bin hier gleich auf dem dach achtung
buch wünsche mir einen beinbruch ich bin
oben
ich bin über die ja ja ich komme auch
ich hab extra
ich bin ein fairer kiste unter gefallen
ich kann auch noch mal hoch ich habe
sowieso gewundert du kannst mit einer
rampe ist wieder profi in japan ran
service auf jeden fall keiner eigentlich
weil mir geht's so also ich hab das war
schon öfters mal gespielt aber ich habe
es geschafft ich bin okay kommst du dir
ja ich habe einfach gesagt der kommt
spielchen eine runde hier mit
spielsachen
aber ich will auch noch ist ich habe
schon die goldmünzen deutschland ich
habe eine eine goldene gamaschen hatte
projektleiter no go back and start die
action merkel geht los
ich glaube wir sollen hier noch mal
schlafen was das hier ja ich bin so
vetter 2
ganz genau wo die ersten abgeschafft
jawohl ich auch der und great place
block gut machen oder hinsetzen laute
break your colours obwohl also es die
dürfen alle blöcke kaputt machen die m
gefärbt sind ja ja die sind auch
gefährte die roten spiel auf normal oder
hart am bauamt ein unser ernst ihr
erzfeind ist der tintenfisch dass mal
ein episches throl face und dann unser
score also unsere punkte sind die sind
die dieburger die gold in genau dieser
schilder lesen entstehen bleiben doch
sicherlich schiller gelesen ich war
griff verstoß vorbei sagte diskret am i
have kidnapped medlocks okay die haben
irgendwie gekidnappt und wir müssen ihn
irgendwie sichern
zu spät steht ja ok weitergeht ob auch
bei youtube ließ make me ist showdown
pop channel and description erwerben die
web-unternehmen before you tube auf im
video viermal natürlich myvideo oder
youporn oder ärger was don't look down
nur das ist mich tief wo sie eigentlich
mit schellen nein nein ich fand dich mal
sprint nur 1 keine chance ja das ist
richtig krass heftig was uns da unten
noch erwartet dass es richtig heftig
judith blog down ich weiß ja ich hab
auch untergebracht wir haben jetzt jeder
zweite rate ich hab da einfach noch zwei
dringen lassen okay der welt vorliegt
dürfen runterfallen tollem eine rüstung
ist weg überlebe ich das heute mal soll
ich komme die do x vor
halte dich hab' war richtig knapp sind
auf höhe 20 deswegen sind auch über
dieses komisches zeug aber bestimmt
gewollt vor mit der entwickler auch hier
sind feuerwerke drin aber wir dürfen da
wahrscheinlich nicht reingucken website
joystiq für delicious potter
das ist ab das sind dann die ersten
punkte für uns okay
ja wahrscheinlich klar ich hab auch ne
ich hab auch schon zwei goldbarren
ehrlich weil das handy war noch in der
kiste oben brennendem haus ja dann hatte
ich nämlich nehmen einfach mal die
ganzen butter teile hier mit dann habe
ich den scorpions es gibt ja auch mal
meine oder du ich hab dann
herunterfallen sind ja deswegen würde
ich sagen dass ich einfach mal die
hälfte gebe von meinen so ok dann habe
ich wohl wie viel hast du denn die kann
man essen
das war gerlinde butter doch so viel
kann man eröffne essen und ich hab da
noch gold bahn und die goldbarren
stellen ja die punkte da also ich kann
meine nicht erst nach so war ich ja
schon komplett hunger dings alt war hier
kommen die us-raketen raus ist ja geil
war also eine recht neue karte auch noch
recht neuen berichts auch nicht lange
comment box ist auch noch nicht allzu
lang bestimmt da unten ist immer cool
maps mitkommen blöcken jetzt auf jeden
fall cool gemacht auf dieses superkraft
bros brawl oder sophie auch sehr
interessant hab ich ja gestern zum
ersten mal gespielt hier genau was ich
ja auch alles aufkommen blöcken nur ein
komisches tripwire us soldat kam nur
lila raketen okay so als dass ihr fragt
euch das mal ganz kurz sieht schon sehr
sehr episch aus übrigens hd kanal ist in
der beschreibung wir werden das
abwechseln aufnehmen und der zweite er
hat eltern bei ihm seine fans vergessen
zu sein genau und damit ihr keine folge
verpasst auf jeden fall franck
abonnieren
frank abonnieren auf jeden fall damit
ihr gar nichts verpasst abgebissen
da könnt ihr den abmessen aber ich denke
mal ich hab noch da geht's hoch ich weiß
nicht ob mir einfach mal schauen oder
hier hinten warte mal ich gucke mich
hier mal um die enden können wir nicht
nur irgendwie sowieso glas blöcke vor
oder so doch hier hinten kann man weiter
ja da ich habe versucht da hoch zu gehen
aber da sind so komisch blöcke vor da
kann man nicht durch das deswegen im
tecdax ok anlegt sehr schön ich finde
karten allgemeinen denken also nicht mit
dem normalen mit einem noch einen extra
jackpot eigentlich richtig coole walter
abgelegt und extrakte von poschinger vom
- einige reifen hier unten hesselmann
ich bin schon so gut wie tot legen sie
wir sind diese gut diese gold betten
simply the party
wie kommt man überhaupt auf die idee
tintenfisch als feind irgendwie rein zu
machen
thaddäus ich gleich selber seine
tintenfisch presse in meinem obwohl ich
habe so eine tadeusz na ja geht darf man
schon wieder runter gefallen komm du
erstmal weiter ich komme gleich vorbei
ich guckte da ganz zu damit du ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz viel druck hast okay
ich schaffe das
ich hoffe dass schwach dass cook gar
nicht erst suchen sogar ich habe das
buch gerade wer bei mir ein bisschen
heimat inzwischen runter wenn du darauf
steigt der wahrscheinlich wenn immer
mehr
du machst uns immer mehr feinde komme
und nach oben stellt maria und ich habe
es geschafft ja wohl was genau es nachts
machen glaube ich ich bin mal wieder
minecraft gott hier war ich lege mich
mal nicht
ich will dich neben dem schlaf bestimmt
hatte
danke immer wieder gerne hallo tag
naja ich habe meine milch noch im bett
ja schon wieder okay da bist du wurden
da ich dachte schon du immer noch bei
mir auch ja irgendwie schon
dann ist ein paar schlaf ich glaube es
ist sinnvoller die die map bei tag zu
machen
damit wäre schumacher wenn wir irgendwie
null sind macht das auch nicht viel aus
ja hier lang mal vor ihr geschafft
rettberg sicherheitsteam auch an damit
ein stück unserer und forschung es mal
schöne butter hier und jetzt
diese butter es macht das sind brote
wahrscheinlich lag wieder schema foto
ist so ein komplettes stück butter
einfach nur wo bin ich hier lange über
die kuppe über der weißen sports alte
alles voll schnell ich bezweifle ich
liebe aber ich komme da ähnlich locker
ich konnte dir ich versuche meine sachen
irgendwie zurückzuholen
wie machen wir das auch so da hinten
wärst du bist ok wartet nimmt auch im
boot mit brot aber ich glaube die werden
zwar die sache zu machen geht aber
erstmal die krippe ok mit bloßen hand
genau
es sind ja auch keine normalen grippe
muss man sagen das sind schon
batteriebetrieb er weggeht weg ihr
blödmänner
warte mal einen spot zurück um eine
rüstung außerhalb nachdruck ich komme
aus dem weg du hast doch schwer heißt
immer der gleichen stelle stehe ich wie
viele krippen finden da haut doch ab
tacke da komme ich nicht lesen
natürlich versucht man schon alltag mit
den experten ganz dann auch er machte
alle sind tot es gebe heute schon wieder
tot
ich schreibe einfach dazu wie schlimm
und ich warte hier auch mal wir am rande
dabei den ich damit ich einfach mal
etwas mit druck dir machen kann
da kommen wir deine freunde die krüper
debatte über den darm und das will ich
wieder ganz viele aber die farbe gehen
alle auf mich hier ja immer ich denke
habe okay ich denke die ab ich lenke ab
ich will meine sachen zurückgaben die
krippe wissen wer der boss ist ein
krieger wissen wer der bar wo ist er
geht immer stärker mittlerweile der
spruch geht immer mittlerweile dass
leute da warum sprechen obwohl viele
wissen ja noch nicht woher der wirklich
kommt warte ich will meine sachen
zurückgeht markieren wieder so viele
varianten bade warte ich lenke
schlagmann 1
ja ja ich bin schon dabei gut ich werde
ich werde er wieder sterben dass ich
öfter mal warte mal ich gehe mal in den
nahkampf und mit ok diesmal werde ich
schaffen mir meine sachen zu holen
ok ich hab' die glaube alle was allmend
sachen ja habe ich
das letzte buch wie kann ja ich hab dir
alle ok erwarte ich komme perfekte gold
hose brauchst du schön bequem wie immer
besonders im mittenbereich weil du es
ist eine sehr bequeme hose
anpassungsfähig auf jeden fall wie in
europa machen die map kaputt alt wäre
verfolger wenn du noch einen töten
würdest dann wäre ich bald tot
das erste bagger schwert des schön
kaputt machen
das kann ich schon wieder die tour ist
mir leid du tust mir wirklich leid die
ganze zeit so jetzt kommt ohne boote ich
hoffe dass jetzt die filme jetzt einfach
durch auf meine sache ich wollte ich
habe meine sachen glaube ich aber nie
der helm fehlt auf jeden fall etwas
fehlt ja der helm der nachdem eine tolle
frisur kaputt von einem weiter stabilen
noch einen krieg bat die anderen dann
kann ich das schnell durchschwimmen okay
ich mache ja ok mach du mal um die ecke
weil ich probiere jetzt noch alle hab
das rennen sprintete weggesteckt einfach
nur sprint elektro ich hab's geschafft
ins geschäft ein glück und ich dachte
schon ich sterbe dann wo bleibst du den
kopf bekommen muss man mal hast du die
sachen schon genau hier genau hier genau
hier hakt noch eine hose dann habe ich
etwas butter findet kleinboot kannst du
behalten du nimmst alles wieder selber
auf irgendwie daneben nur das boot habe
ich bekommen
okay hier und da hier ich hab kein
schwert mehr gemeinheit
eigentlich hab auch gibst du gehst den
ganzen müll einfach ich packe ich habe
eure holzbretter entdecker für euch da
kann ich mit schwert machen aus stein
doppler hose beim klar warum denn nicht
haben wir eine werkbank bestimmt hier in
gottes namen wie sagen wir drei hosen
ich habe 201
ich habe glaube ich von etwas mehr
mitgenommen
okay kommt weiter geht's in dem und
crafting tempel ist wäre das sehr geil
hat mal wieder richtig verfressen dabei
jene gleich alles ausgenommen etwa
sofort butter fressen sind wir überhaupt
richtig ja ich glaub schon da ging es
sich hoch dann gehen so leiter runter
aber da kann man nicht drüber sprechen
hier lang
darum ist nix europas auf ich habe es
nicht geschafft das bild natürlich
treuen fans natürlich muss dabei sein
ich glaube man muss einfach nur sprinten
oder geht auch nicht denken ich hab
jetzt schon nur noch reichen holzbretter
dich platzieren könnte darf man aber
nicht
schade ich glaube ich sterbe hier noch
per handy peinlich wenn die lautstärke
versteht sich besonders darüber schaffen
wie du hast mich geschlagen und dadurch
man das schafft man das schafft man doch
eigentlich nur gut dass und keine ahnung
ist eine knappe geschichte hier auf
jeden fall kurz geschaltet winslow und
in aixtrons rennen rennen rennen rennen
rennen online scheiße gebaut
und da ist eine kiste noch gerne sehen
wenn die gäste übersehen du hast mehr
rüstung warte ich probiert ich stark
meint peter ja toll 6 wartet die sendung
wasser kacke den wir kriegen jetzt auf
dem feld da wurde die hitze schnell
goldbarren weil ich nein nein
hackl der erste tod ist dritteln wo bin
ich denn hier nein ich kann mir den
kompletten weg laufen
ich habe deine sachen ok oh nein ich
lass mich in ruhe was ich würde nicht
sterben an der stelle bis für mich wir
bei dem wasserbecken hier oben mit dem
boden und da möchte ich hin oder ach da
ich dachte da kommt später ganz viele
kritiker ausgepackten fest das sind
schafft das wissen wir alle ihr wollt
ihr auch ich habe hier bestimmt acht
pieper bei mir und ich darf ja keine
blöcke sitzt wird erstmal der rüstung an
alltag
nein richtig africa ich bin an der
stelle wo du vorhin auch immer gestorben
bist ja ich will dich zurück zu kommen
aber wir sind selber der krippe hier
bleibt man aber vor noch zurück kommst
hast noch meine sachen bekommen wir
liegen die salben und außerhalb
eigentlich so gut wie alles von dir
perfekt explodiert bei mir gut ich
halbem app einfach hier bei mir auch
jetzt sehr wie viele kritiker immer
wieder ja bei mir auch
unglaublich aber ich schaffe das hören
weder schaffen
du musst einfach ja wir schaffen das
cluster den checkpoint da hinten gesetzt
oder ach nee das war auch an ist nicht
ihr sollten uns vielleicht öfters
checkpoint sets mit den berlinern
wir haben doch nur ein witz wir haben
keine betten dabei müssen uns genau
überlegen wo wir acht stimmen so hallo
das kommt immer mehr wo bleibst du
moment ich komme vorbei
ich hoffe dass ich hoffe dass das war
knapp gerade ja wohl richtig eng jetzt
die sind richtig viele krieter los und
ich wollte nicht hoch es ist gut okay
ich bin wieder da an der stelle wo wir
vorhin immer davon der bist du allein
hier sind derbe viele creeper einfach
nur die ich komme halt an allen einfach
nicht ran weil die attacke
na ja danke bitte könnt ihr nun etwa den
zaun abbauen und dann bekommt man das
ganz legal hier
dort warten schon glück aber auch wissen
willst du dich war schon mal da sind der
wie viele lauf einfach durch davon will
wie viel ist das schafft man nicht
unmöglich hieß unter apples wieder
krüper richtig viele schaffst mich nicht
ich weiß es nicht wir unterkommen oder
daheim auf jeden fall sind wir beide
wieder tot man die kommen auch alle nach
hier packe ich glaube du kommst noch
nicht mehr
ich weiß jetzt noch jeder hinkommen da
bist du ja ja hinten sind jedoch viel
mehr habt ja ich weiß
kommt alle zu mir ich weiß nicht
darunter gehen und einfach mal versuchen
die ganzen druck oder versuchst hier
wirklich irgendwie rüberzukommen
vielleicht kann ich auch irgendwann
checkpoint aufmachen oder so für dich ja
normalerweise müsste ja nur ein kribbeln
wieder hinten hochgehen wenn eine
hochgeht dann werden ja eigentlich so
gut wie alle tot
also hier ist ein wasserfall aber den
kann ich nicht offen machen und blöcke
darf ich nicht abbauen sonst solche mal
die druckplatten abbauen thema neue
grippe mir bescheren
aber ich würde erstmal sagen dass wir
das allgemeine der nächsten folge sehen
weil das jetzt schon wieder sich den 20
minuten zu neigt sich gerade auch okay
du hast du folgen wenn wir etwas länger
machen macht ja nix genau deswegen bin
ich einfach sagen zweite folge der bgh
die auf dem kanal der ist in der
beschreibung und dann sehen wir uns dort
wieder und schauen ob wir das schaffen
mit dem genauer bei der dritten folge
sind wir wieder auf dem kanal genau dies
bis zum nächsten mal